-Welcome back to "Late Night"!
We're here with Amber Ruffin
and Lacey Lamar.
They're sisters.
They're wonderful.
Amber works for this show.
Amber, you also have your own
show, "The Amber Ruffin Show."
You recently had --
I mean, I guess,
a hero of both of yours.
Is hero the right word
for El DeBarge?
-Hero, husband...
[ Laughter ]
-Idol.
-Hey, jinx!
-Jinx.
[ Light laughter ]
-So there you are.
So, Lacey, you're on the show.
There's El DeBarge there.
There you are, Lacey.
Were you -- Could you be in the
moment, or was it all a blur?
-No, I don't remember anything.
I think I was hovering over my
body, watching that happen.
I don't know what I said.
-Did El DeBarge enjoy his time,
or did he feel maybe
like a little stalked?
-I was terrified
he would have a bad time,
so I talked to him
as little as possible.
I was scared!
[ Laughter ]
-I did not.
We hung out and became friends.
[ Laughter ]
-They did, they did.
-It should be noted,
El DeBarge has been very
taken care of you guys.
This was the first dedication
of your first book.
-Yeah.
-"This book is dedicated
to Black mothers and fathers,
like James and Theresa Ruffin,
who teach us how to deal
with racism,
to Black brothers and sisters
like Chrystal, Angela,
and Jimmy,
who provide support,
and Black children like Amani
who hopefully have it easier
than we did.
And most of all, this book
is dedicated to El DeBarge.
You are truly
the Rhythm of the Night."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-He is.
-And then...
-I love him.
-...I want to note
you had a chance, obviously,
to have a second dedication
to maybe cover
more people in your life.
-Yeah.
-Throw a wider net.
"This book is dedicated
to all white people everywhere.
Just kidding.
The opposite of that."
[ Laughter ]
"This book is dedicated
to our family and friends
who experienced
all these stories with us.
Just kidding.
This book
is dedicated to El DeBarge."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It is.
Some would say everything we do
is dedicated to him.
-I know you're a talented
writer, Lacey.
I did not realize the -- the --
the depths
of your artistic talent.
-I know
what you're about to show,
and that was my fourth grade...
-Fourth grade?
-...art project, yes.
-This was your fourth grade
art project?
[ Laughter ]
-And you know that's good.
-That is good.
-Isn't it great?
[ Applause ]
-You guys --
-But wait, wait.
It's on my mantel right now.
-It's on her mantel right now!
-You framed it?
-No.
It's just hanging there.
-It's just hanging there.
[ Laughter ]
-Is it just, like, a loose piece
of fourth-grade paper?
-Oh, it's on a board.
-It's on a board --
it's on a canvas.
-Oh, it's on a canvas.
-It's pencil on canvas, Seth.
-Oh, pencil on canvas.
-[ Laughs ] El DeBarge
is looking everywhere.
-I'm waiting for it to come up
at auction at Christie's.
-Listen, I'm not selling that.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, you're doing the countdown
to the Macy's Thanksgiving Day
Parade, Amber.
-Yay!
-On Wednesday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love
the Thanksgiving Day Parade.
-You have always loved --
you love a --
I mean, I know this sounds
like a song in a musical.
You love a parade.
-♪ I love a parade ♪
I super do.
Sometimes I forget
what holiday it is.
The parade comes out our window
at work, and we can watch it.
-Yeah.
-And I used to watch it
like this out of our window,
you know, because we look over
Rockefeller Center
and the tree and stuff.
And I would watch the parade
like this,
and Michelle Wolf would be
two desks down talking about,
"I hate parades!"
[ Laughter ]
-Where do you come out
on parades?
-I love a parade.
-You love a parade, too.
-It's amazing.
-It's so prancy.
-Yeah, I do.
I love a parade.
I worked one time
at a retirement home,
and I wasn't the only person
that did this,
but we actually were counting
our residents that we had.
And we had seven,
and I kept counting seven.
And then, one time I looked,
and we counted six.
And Charlene went by on a horse.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know why I shared that.
But I do love parades.
-That should've been
in the book!
[ Laughter ]
-Is it exciting when you see
the book on a shelf?
Do you like going to a bookstore
and seeing the Ruffin girls?
-We love it.
-The book's on the shelf
downstairs, Seth,
in this very building.
-Is it really?
-Yes.
-It is.
-Not the new one, sorry.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sorry I said that.
-But if people
don't have the old one --
-The old one is downstairs.
-Uh-huh.
-And that is very cute to pass
when you go
into your job every day.
-Now, you had El DeBarge on
"The Amber Ruffin Show"
this year.
You've had some other real
sort of bucket-list guests.
-First of all,
we had El DeBarge on,
and we played a game with him
called "Know Your El DeBarge,"
and we beat him.
[ Laughter ]
-What do you mean "we"?
I won.
-Lacey won. Lacey did win.
-Did he get any El DeBarge
questions right?
-Yeah. Like, he knew
where he was born, but...
[ Laughter ]
-He didn't know enough.
-No.
We had Babyface on,
and he played a game called
"Name That Ooh," where I "oohed"
oohs and aahs from songs
he wrote, and he had to guess --
[ Laughter ] --
what song it was from.
-How did he do?
-He was, um, disappointed...
[ Laughter ]
...in my ability
to convey the music.
-Gotcha.
He put it on you.
-Yeah.
He wasn't wrong.
-All right.
That's very kind of you
to not blame it on Babyface,
yeah.
It is always so lovely
to have you guys.
Thank you for being here with us
on this week of family.
I know you guys are family, but
you're also family to this show,
and it is so lovely to be here
together with you guys.
Congratulations.
Two books!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Two books and an art --
and a masterpiece.
[ Laughter ]
Amber Ruffin and Lacey Lamar,
everybody.
"The World Record Book
of Racist Stories"
is available now
wherever you buy your books.
Please support local
and independent bookstores.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."